[Music] citizens of the reject Nation I am
joining with my buddy Aron Alexander today
because we just covered the Invincible season
2 trailer and we covered Invincible season 1
together we covered Invincible Adam Eve together
so he's my Invincible partner right here my omn
man if you will that's what people call him
around town it's a compliment believe it or
not anyway they released this trailer for
Mortal Kombat 1 and we didn't do haven't
done any of recover from Mortal Kombat 1
I know some people been like where's all
recover we haven't done it last time around it
all got yellow dollar bill signs we're going to
risk it today because ZN man first look at
this I just watched the combat pack reveal
trailer I skimmed it cuz I wanted to see the
image are you excited Aaron oh my God I'm so
excited I'm excited too that was boring it's
only one minute long that's crazy I feel like
you can really bring like we'll talk more about
it after but I feel like there's a lot of great
potential you have destroyed worlds I have erased
whole time timelines finally a worthy
challenge damn it looks so real yeah
right you get actual JK Simmons
it sounds like him wow oh dude
this kind of oh my God oh my God oh
dude look out of the show claim this
timeline for the bilum Empire you will
burn for the in it works in the story
line awesome O Let's see it you going do the
trade you going do the trade thing yes oh
oh that perfect hell yeah wow he it works so so
seamlessly into Mortal Kombat yeah who would have
th I feel like he could destroy everyone though oh
he would easily everybody on a narrative level he
would destroy everyone on a Nar but Greg behind
the controller would I am so bad I love playing
Mortal Kombat I have I love verse like I have
friends where I just verse them but I haven't
actually played through a story in ages uh but
I when I heard omn I'm like oh that's perfect
because it's one thing to take a real life action
character and they pulled it off many times before
and sometimes it works better than others but
when you take a real life character or one from
a liveaction medium I mean and then you place
them into Mortal Kombat sometimes aesthetically
it looks cool but video game wise it doesn't
translate as well but omn man is an animated
character so when you tell me he's going to be
in Mortal Kombat and like yeah that I feel like
you can definitely pull it off he's already an
animated character and you can probably bring the
motion the action the flying the entire movement
to life and I think the thing that surprised me
about this visually was kind of the odity of he's
still animated but he looks more photo realistic
than when you watch the Amazon Prime show so had
this like weird upgrade in computer animation
because he's supposed to look more hum like he's
not exactly plucked out of the show because he
looks more real yeah he look like a real man yeah
so it's a little charring to me but I love that
because it still distinguishes and separates it
from the animated uh its animated counterpart
uh but yeah what' you think man I thought it
was great no I couldn't agree with you more I
thought the the fact that it seems like it sounds
like JK Simmons which is really cool and the fact
that they're using some of the same imagery and
some of the devastating things we saw at the end
of season one of the show is is like such a cool
callback and yeah I couldn't agree more the fact
that he seamlessly fits into the show and even
the way he moves like granted you we've had like
guest characters in Mortal Kombat before but
something about the way he moves even in the
actual fighting that's beyond the cut scenes just
feels so omn man it feels like that you feel the
the visceral nature of this this Powerhouse and
they have even some of the his characteristics
or like his uh his lore into there and kind
of how you were saying it fits perfectly into
the the nature of this game cuz what isn't Mortal
Kombat in in and of itself like a Multiverse kind
of a tourn yeah and the tournament of Realms yeah
exactly uh yeah I thought there was a lot of cool
very cool things and it's very violent and the
show's very violent and the comic's very violent
and the game is very violent so it's like the
perfect marriage I'm EXC beautiful Union what
I'm looking forward to and and I wonder if they
got Anthony star to play him in Mortal Kombat
because you have the you have homelander coming
into this as well yeah what's their dialogue like
together what are the dialogue scenes going to be
like back back and forth are going to bring that
dream to life I really feel like I really feel
like because specula about this in our Invincible
season 2 reaction that somehow they're going to
cross over Invincible in the boys I think they're
going to do it in some way that would be so Co
um but to see the crossover happen in a video
game format where you're going to bring like the
an the the animation styles to make them similar
so they feel like they're in the same universe you
know so you're going to get like two differences
you're going to get omn man who is very much an
animation character look a little bit more photo
realistic you're going to take homelander who's
a liveaction character and make him look more
animated yeah then you're going to meet them
in the middle but their powers are already so
similar yeah you know so I'm wondering how they
can help distinguish that in some capacity where
you you don't feel like you're just playing
someone with a different skin you know it's
not just like switching between rayu and Ken I've
upset someone who's like actually rayu Ken is the
exact they're the exact same all right just one's
Japanese the other guy's white all right they're
the exact same but the but it's like that's that
is the one part of it where I'm like I'm excited
at the prospect of seeing homelander and omn man
of course go be able to play against each other
I think it's really cool but I do want to see what
will make them different ultimately um when you're
playing the game I think the the interesting
thing that I hope they would bring to the game
is that you know in the universe of the boys no
one's really as strong as homelander so he never
really has to fight that much so I feel like I
hope his fighting looks like it's taking like
minimal effort because he's like the strongest
person strongest being in that Universe right
but you know we'll we'll see what that what that
looks like I would just hope that when they come
to blows it's just such a satisfying experience
because those are the two Superman figures within
their universes and I'm I'm really surprised
that they put those two in the same game yeah
yeah man to see what that would even uh come to
also Peacemaker John Cena there too get his ass
whooped easily it's just cool that the fatalities
themselves are fatalities that actually cuz a lot
of times when you when you do the fatalities of
the adaptations when you take these these uh movie
or TV show characters and put them in Mortal
Kombat you have to really invent something we
haven't seen yeah and for their fatalities they're
just pulling from the show yeah I like he that's
literally the end of one episode when he crushes
that guy's skull yeah that the train thing is one
of the most memorable moments you know so comic
apparently that's something stly I think that's
so cool though that the fatalities themselves are
are just pulled directly from the series itself
instead of like and I think that's like even more
of a of a dream come true in some ways you know
I there's a lot of really great ways to do it
and who knows who knows maybe they'll crossover
Mortal Kombat into Invincible um one of these days
actually you know would not mind that it would be
very cool but you know what and also on Mortal
Kombats level what a great way to just even if
you're not into Mortal Kombat you're probably like
well I want to play this I want to try it out it's
great marketing gimmick an amazing marketing um
it's cool because we didn't see omn man return in
the trailer for invincible season 2 we did not
but he's here and it's JK Simmons apparently I
just looked it uh on the description box uh that's
neat all righty guys what did you think about this
trailer leave your thoughts down below uh I had
a great time watching this one Aaron what would
you rate this trailer uh 10 out of 10 10 out
of 10 for sure man that was amazing that was
amazing I feel bad I'm missing on all these Mortal
Kombat trailers but this one felt very special
yeah I agree I loved it leave your thoughts
Down Below guys uh we will talk with all of
you guys very soon and also watch our Invincible
season 2 trailer peace out reject [Music] Nation